it is time for this week's sin
city chronicles a weekly look back at
vegas history and happenings
march 16 1984 was the night the prince
of darkness
arrived in las vegas
[Music]
ozzy osbourne's bark at the moon tour
was at the thomas and mack
this was ozzie's first vegas concert the
opening act
was an unknown group at the time called
motley crew
now march is a big month for mike tyson
we're looking at his first fight which
was in 1986
and tyson had a couple of big knockouts
in march of 1991 at the mirage
he had a seventh round tko against razor
running
now the right combination still steps in
is it over it's over and the knockout
against franco bruno in 1996
to win the wbc heavyweight title at the
mgm
grand this is a combination uppercut by
tyson
tyson
[Applause]
unstoppable tyson is 6-0 in fights in
march just look at him
non-stop comedian jerry lewis he was
known for his slapstick comedy
which ended up causing serious injuries
i actually love these vintage photos
that we show
march 20th 1969 jerry lewis fell off a
piano while performing at the sands
lewis broke bones in his spine leaving
him with constant pain
for the rest of his life wow this is the
sundance hotel which opened up downtown
in 1980
it was eventually sold and on st
patrick's day 1988 it reopened as the
fitzgerald's
las vegas first irish steam casino
at 34 stories high it was the tallest
building in downtown las vegas at the
time
and inside gamblers they can get an
extra dose of luck
by kissing a chunk of the blarney stone
the
fitzgerald would later become the d
hotel and the blarney stone is still
inside just don't kiss it maybe touch it
with everything that's that's going on
right now